Love is an intense and life-changing experience.
Some of them believe in true love,
while others claim that it's a deep, unconditional feeling.
Sounds over the top, right?
Either way,
people go "gaga" over it.
After all,
what's life without love?
Here are 5 interesting facts about love.
1. It only takes 4 minutes to
decide whether you like someone or not.
This actually has very little to do with smooth talking
and other conventional flirting techniques.
In fact, it's mostly dependent on body language,
the tone and speed of our voice.
Only 7% of what we say actually matters.
2. Your nerve cells work better during the first year
of being in a loving relationship.
Everyone's bodies contain a protein called
"Nerve Growth Factor,"
which is responsible for the functioning of some of our sensory nerves.
This protein tends to work more effectively during
the first year that you're in love with someone.
When we're in love, our senses are heightened,
and our "Fight or Flight" response system is on-guard.
It's the most optimal during the early stages of love,
which is why couples in love feel
more happy and optimistic.
Falling in love can be as addictive as nicotine.
Have you heard of dopamine?
Most people who've heard of it knows that it involves good feelings.
They're exactly right.
Dopamine is a chemical that's released during
the initial stage of the relationships.
It's responsible for the rush of pleasure
and excitement we often experience.
Since dopamine's also activated when you use nicotine,
you can imagine how addictive love can be.
4. Many adolescents who experience puppy crushes,
also experience a lot of anxiety.
Teenagers often get a bad rep from popular culture,
for being rebellious and over idealistic
about their future.
But parents, and adults should be more considerate
when teenagers experience puppy crushes.
According to Dr. Carl Pickhardt from Psychology Today,
the awakening of romantic feelings can cause
significant anxiety
and those who are still trying to figure out their own identity.
If you're sensitive about the way others perceive you,
and want to have a strong desire to belong,
your desire for intimate attachment
and bonding could lead to anxiety about
potentially losing it.
5. True love is friendship set on fire.
Thanks to Hollywood, people mistake fighting and make-up sex
for true, passionate love.
But, according to research, true love manifests
as supporting one another's interests,
growing together,
and being considerate of each other's feelings.
In other words, you're besties!
Despite all the research done on love,
to this day, it still remains an enigma.
Which of these facts did you find the most interesting?
What do you think? Leave a comment below.
Don't forget to also subscribe to our channel,
and share this video to get a free copy of our magazine!
With your help, we can reach more people to spread awareness
on mental health issues, and explore
illusive topics like this together.
Thanks for watching~!